hey, white woman,
please stop comparing your experiences to ours.
so I listen to a really great podcast
that I think summarizes my experience
as a woman of color in the workplace.
it's called The Brown Table Talk.
in these 2 fabulous women talk about the challenges
women of color face in the workplace.
before we dive in
DC Marshall is a powerhouse
in the DEI space.
she has her own company
that works with an organization to improve diversity,
equity and inclusion.
Maria is a marketing genius
and now she's ahead of inclusion at Carter
where she is a DEI champion
and I just want to clarify this video
and their podcast is not meant to stir the pot.
it is supposed to help white women
have some insight into the conversations
women of color
or maybe having behind their backs.
alright, let's get into it.
we tend to lump women together
with the intent of being inclusive.
we assume that women
everywhere are having the same thoughts and experiences.
but what we don't do is give room for each different
woman's unique experiences and thoughts.
basically, what I'm trying to say
is that there is a difference between
white women and women of color
because women of color face an intersectionality
of being both a person of color and a woman.
let's start with an example.
I am getting yelled at by my boss.
he's telling me that I'm disagreeable,
unfriendly and hard to work with.
get really upset about the situation
and go vent to my white female colleague in the office.
my white female colleague
in effort to make me feel better.
says that the same thing happened to her
and that our boss is just a jerk and a sexist.
here's the thing that my white female colleague missed.
she forgot about the fact that I am a person of color.
I'm not only having sexist experiences.
but I may also be having racist experiences
with my boss.
all I can appreciate my colleague
trying to share her story
about the same thing that happened to her.
the difference is
I am a woman of color.
so my experience
might have had
underlying racism in the situation.
what she should have done
is just listened
and asked how she could have helped.
I want to give you one more example
that describes the challenges that women of color
are facing in the workplace.
stick with me here.
have you ever heard of Employee Resource Groups
which are organizations at companies
that are meant to accelerate DEI at the firm.
see this one right here
called Win Right
women's Interactive Network
Employee Resource Group
which is meant for women and women of color.
did you hear what I said?
I said women and women of color.
when I really meant white
women and women of color.
because when we say things like
we are assuming that the women part just means
white women. right.
so why are we normalizing that the word
women only refers to white women?
that's because
when we look at gender history in this country,
it has all been in the lens of white women.
and you'll notice that these employee resource groups
disproportionately benefit white women.
you may start to notice that the women
employee resource groups
at your company are mostly made up of white women.
and that is because your women of color colleagues
feel more included with their racial groups at work
next time you're talking to a woman of color.
please keep in mind that not only are they a woman,
but they are also a person of color.